[Music]
hey there Liliana here I'm an Operations
program manager here at Google and I
work on our maps and search products and
hi for me
Samad I'm a curriculum developer here at
Google to developing GCP Enterprise and
sales training on this episode we'll be
looking at cloud data proc a faster
easier more cost-effective way to run
Apache spark and Apache Hadoop will also
take you through a quick demo of a
self-paced lab where we use the GCP
console to create a cloud data Proctor
run a simple spark job and change the
number of worker nodes if you're using
popular data processing tools like
Hadoop and spark you're probably
spending more time than you want on
managing the balance between cost
complexity scale and utilization
absolutely when I've got vast quantities
of data to process I want to be focusing
on the insights provided not the cluster
processing it as a managed spark and
Hadoop cloud service cloud data product
makes these powerful data tools easy to
use what you don't want to be worrying
about in data processing is cost and
complexity using spark in Hadoop
shouldn't break the bank so on top of
the other GCP resources you use there's
only a small incremental fee payable per
virtual CPU in your cluster data proc
automation also helps you save money by
turning clusters off when you don't need
them with Billy in one second clock time
increments subject to a women at minimum
you also only pay for what you use
now time for quick labs and this
hands-on app will use the GCP console to
create a data proctor run a simple
apache spark job then modify the number
of workers in the cluster there's a
separate lab where the same activities
can be completed using the g-cloud COI -
you can check out the links to start the
cook labs here each lab will take about
30 minutes to complete so far in the lab
we've created a data proctor in the US
central region we navigate to the data
product jobs view we submit a sample
spark job that calculates the value of
pi' we check the job output we can see
the value of pi' that was calculated by
the job in the lab you'll also have the
opportunity to change the number of
worker instances in your cluster we hope
you enjoyed this episode we'd love to
hear how cloud data proc has improved
how you run spark and Hadoop so please
get in touch and if you haven't signed
up for the $300 free trial credit on GCP
check out this link it's a great way to
apply what you've learned all of our
additional training resources are linked
below thanks again for watching and see
you soon
you